well eveline pankers the founder of the
suffragette movement is an historic
feminist icon the trans rights
protesters disagree this weekend a group
called themselves manchester trans rise
up just like paramilitaries complete
with balaclavas and forcefully stopped a
women's rights campaign group from
holding an event next to a statue of
pankhurst
appalling scenes they also tied the
trans rights flag around the statue's
waist like an apron
well jk rowling shared the video of the
clash on twitter she said i never
expected the right side of history to
include so many people in masks
intimidating and assaulting women did
you
so can trans rights coexist with women's
rights it's all getting very emotive and
very heated in a moment i'll be speaking
to women's rights activist kelly j king
who was speaking on that day but first
trans woman and activist jane not her
real name she's wearing a mask to
protect her identity joins me from the
site of the protest jane welcome
hey pears it's good to hear your voice
you know well it's good
honestly it's good to talk to you i want
to have a proper debate with you it's an
uncensored show so you can speak your
mind here's my question for you you're
standing at the side of where all this
went down when you see the video footage
of members of your group that day and
you were there
members of the group basically
physically assaulting a woman who was
sitting there what do you feel
i i feel annoyed because the footage is
cut and it doesn't show them storming in
shoving people over that little bit of
concrete over there which is kind of
dangerous you know you could hurt your
head quite a lot doing that it doesn't
show them shoving
strangling and kicking people
um
and there's also not the you know i said
i think i sent footage to the producers
of the show i doubt that i doubt you
guys will want to show it but we've got
other footage of the same turfs that
came over and tried to assault us there
strangling and punching people at other
protests they'd like to play the victim
so i think if you don't mind me saying
you're playing slight what about so i
only really want to know what is your
reaction to the footage we have seen
which clearly shows some of the people
that you were with
assaulting a woman i mean you can't be
happy that that is the image that your
group has now
seen around the world is doing
i mean i mean first firstly i would say
as i as i just said you know
uh the footage is cut you can't see the
start of the footage um and the people
dressed in black who are our security to
protect members vulnerable members of
our community
they are there defending themselves
because these women came in when we were
already having a peaceful protest there
and started attacking us they will spin
it the other way jk will spin it the
other way they'll spin it the other way
but that is what happened it's just they
have a lot more money and power than us
so it's easier for them to get a reach
and message but let me ask you what i
would say you know the way the way
the way i really feel about that um
i think it's i think it was a good thing
that we came to that you said it was
because we didn't like emmeline it's
although we didn't like emmeline she was
racist she was also a tory so you know
we probably wouldn't have got on with
her but our big issue was that we don't
want these hateful transphobic women
coming in some of whom kelly j keane for
example is a is a big racist a big
conspiracy theorist an anti-vaxxer a
fascist
uh we don't want these people coming in
and standing next to this this icon of
of feminism
um they are appropriating the imagery of
the suffragette movement a movement for
women's liberation and and rebranding it
as this hateful movement against trans
people for that and the majority of
women the majority of feminists don't
stand for all right let me let me put my
cards on the table i've always supported
trans rights to fairness and equality
and i mean that sincerely i want
everyone
bro well you can say bro and that's fine
you're entitled to it's an uncensored
show and you've just proven it but but
let me just say to you i always wasn't
your profile picture
identified
there's no point there's no point
swearing i apologize to our viewers for
your bad language this is a chance for
you to present yourself in a way where
we can have a proper debate if you've
got no interest in doing that that's
fine but i'm just going to say to you
that i've always supported trans rights
to fairness and equality my issue with
what the way this trans debate is going
is in issues like sport for example
where i think it's very unfair that
trans women should be competing against
women born to female biological bodies i
have issues about safety for women i
have issues about other areas of women's
rights do you understand what have you
finished let me ask you a question do
you understand and appreciate what all
these dog whistles and talking points
they're not dog whistles and talking
points
they are legitimate areas of concern you
can't just call everyone who disagrees
with you
please
if you keep swearing i'll have to kill
you you can go and have a look at their
websites you can have a look at their
twitters
like they are transphobic but i am
okay look look i'm trying to give you a
chance i've explained my position
what is your problem with my position
i don't really know i'm going to leave
the interview now i kind of only came on
here because i thought it would be kind
of funny but i want to say you're and
you're
all right well i apologize again to all
uh viewers who are listening to that
unfortunately a complete idiot which is
what we saw from the video
uh and we hoped we could have a
reasonable conversation but that is
unfortunately what we saw in the video
very unpleasant pieces of work they
think it's fine to come on a show like
this pretend to debate and then engage
in just uh abusive language that's fine
let's go to kelly uh jay king kelly j
keane
i want to talk to you about
this issue because you were on the
receiving end as a group there you were
trying to
uh speak at emmeline pankar statue i've
just had a pretty you know unsavory
exchange with one of those protesters
who probably thinks that they've had
that little moment with me and they'll
get their little viral moment i actually
think it's indicative
of actually how awful uh their behavior
has been throughout this episode and the
way they've dealt with it afterwards but
let me ask you you're very
strong about supporting women's rights
to the point where many say that you are
transphobic do you are you transphobic
well i think in 2022 transphobic really
just means i don't think women have
penises and so yeah i i absolutely am
so you're proud of being transphobic
yeah i'm proud of standing up for
women's rights and and making the word
woman completely exclusive to just women
uh adult human females 100 well you see
but here's my problem with that because
uh whilst i have a problem with the last
guest who chose to be abusive and
unpleasant and wasn't listening to a
word i said i've always supported trans
rights to fairness and equality i don't
see a need to
say i'm transphobic towards them or to
alienate them in any way at all and i
have a problem when you proudly boast of
being transphobic i can see why on the
other side of this argument that kind of
rhetoric
would be very unhelpful to people who
are trans
right well i guess we have a little bit
of an issue with definitions but
when it comes to words like transphobia
it's simply used to silence women like
myself who are trying to protect women's
spaces language and rights and so
if i have to wear that label in order to
speak the truth and i'm happy to do it i
really there is nothing that that can
stop me from speaking about what harms
and danger uh there is for women uh when
we try and dilute what the word woman
means and we allow that language to be
used for men yeah i i
listen i agree with a lot of what you
say i've i've talked about this a lot
and i think there are serious issues
about the infringement on women's rights
as people try and progress trans rights
to where they want to get to which is
fairness and equality you can't create a
new unfairness a new inequality but i
don't think it's helpful to the debate
for you to say i'm transphobic because
that means that you are by your own
mission hateful towards the trans
community that's what it means
transphobia
yeah but it doesn't though does it
because that uh person just called you
transphobic um and i think you've said
numerous times even this evening that
you are pro-trans rights what whatever
that means um and so
if you give an inch i feel uh then we
really do give everything up and so i'm
just look it's just a word it just
transphobic what is that i've never
assaulted anyone i've never incited
violence i don't even know what
transphobia means besides uh refusal to
submit to this ideology and i just i
just won't
i think there needs to be a better
consensus between the two warring
factions on this because i have a lot of
sympathy for a lot of what you say i
also have sympathy with the trans
community who do feel that increasingly
a lot of the rhetoric about them is
transphobia i don't think it really
helps to debate if you say i'm
transphobic because you know that will
uh cause a lot of anger towards them and
why play that game if you feel that they
are playing a game with you why not be
the bigger person in the debate and say
all right how do we get to a place of
genuine fairness and equality for all
well look we could have gone into the
conversation where you say you're
transphobic and i'm like no i'm not
transphobic and then uh we continue from
there and we might have a debate about
what transphobia means i'm just happy
just to put that out the way just to
talk about women's rights uh when we
talk about trans rights in 2022 we're
predominantly saying allowing access to
women's spaces for men who call
themselves women
that's what we're talking about we're
talking about teaching this nonsense in
schools we're talking about uh mutilated
kids bodies with hormones that's what
we're talking about so i'm really really
happy to totally keep the word woman and
women's spaces and under no
circumstances whatsoever allow any born
males in um we can dress it up we can
call it whatever we like i can sit here
and tell you i'm not transphobic because
transphobia means accepting that there
are something uh called trans and then
saying that i hate them
i don't hate anybody i feel quite sorry
for uh particularly um people like
the person who is standing in the statue
i think a lot of them are really
vulnerable kids that have been fed a lie
um and they're going to wake up when
they're about 30 and look back and just
ask themselves what on earth they've
done with that okay
kelly j i gotta leave it there but thank
you for joining me
thank you and just to reiterate
apologies to anyone who was uh offended
by the pretty appalling language you
heard from our first guest in that
debate it's a shame i wanted to have a
rational sensible debate uh
they didn't so that's it
they won't be back
and we move on